[MUSIC]
Hello, and welcome to our webcast,
MBA Student Insights,
a Q&A with
the Hispanic Business Student Association.
My name's Ana Leyva, and I'm a first
year MBA student here at the GSB.
And Co-President of
the Hispanic Business Student Association.
I'm joined by Danny Reyes, Madisen Obiedo,
Maitane Sagastuy, and David Vasquez.
Who are also MBA students here and
members of
the Hispanic Business Student Association.
We'll be talking about our
journey through the GSB,
the student experience here on campus.
And HBSA, of course, and answering
as many of your questions as we can.
To submit a question to us,
simply click on the Q & A button
at the bottom of your screen.
Please note that we won't be
answering questions about admissions,
the application process, or financial aid.
So if you have questions about those
topics, submit them directly to
admissions by emailing
mba.admissions@gsb.stanford.edu.
We'll be starting with some introductions,
Danny, Madisen, Maitane, and David,
please start by sharing
a little bit about you.
Where you're from,
what you were doing before the GSB, and
what your plans are for after graduation,
Danny, let's start with you.
>> Sure, so, hi everyone,
I'm Danny Reyes, I am from Miami,
Florida, come from Cuban
immigrant parents.
Before the GSB,
I studied business undergrad at Penn.
And then I worked in Consulting at
BCG out of their Chicago office,
spent two years there.
And then I worked for a year at the PGA
tour where I spent another year,
and after that I came to the GSB.
And then after GSB, I'm looking to
stay with BCG in consulting and
work on some long term plans to
work in the sports industry.
>> Thanks, Danny, Madisen?
>> Sure, good morning everyone, my name is
Madisen Obiedo, I'm from Dallas, Texas.
My dad is a second generation American,
his family is originally from Mexico,
Northern Mexico, specifically.
I studied ethnic studies at Brown,
with a focus on migration studies, after,
I'm sorry, after Brown,
I went on a Fulbright to Mexico.
Where I worked with
nonprofit organizations and
taught English at the law school.
After that, I did a hard pivot to the
private sector with crisis PR at a small
firm in New York.
After the GSB, I'm hoping to go into
consulting for a couple of years.
And longer term,
start my own nonprofit focused on
immigrant communities in the US.
>> Thanks, Madisen, Maitane?
>> So I grew up in Mexico City until I
was 18, I did my undergrad in the UK.
I studied politics, philosophy and
economics at Warwick, and
then subsequently I joined
the financial services industry.
I'm working for a bank in Asia and the
Middle East, and then, the GSB, of course.
Now, I'm not exactly sure
what I want to do afterwards.
So I'm experimenting with
different industries and
locations to kind of find
exactly what's the next step.
>> Great, and David?
>> Hi everyone, my name is David Vasquez.
I'm from Brooklyn, New York,
where I went to Columbia for
undergrad where I studied economics.
After Columbia,
I went to investment baking,
then I did some stint in private equity.
Then I actually pivoted to non-profit and
I did that for two years.
At the GSB, I'm also a joint degree
student with a Masters in public policy.
And long term, I'm hoping to
do social impact investing and
hopefully pivot my career between
public and private sectors.
>> Awesome, as for me, I'm from the San
Francisco Bay area, my mom is from Mexico,
my dad's from Nicaragua.
And before coming to the GSB, I studied
international relations at Princeton
undergrad, and
then worked in enterprise tech sales.
And after the GSB, I will probably
be running my family business.
Okay, so now that we have
introductions out of the way,
let's start with your questions.
Question one,
what made you decide to apply to and
attend Stanford over other schools?
>> For me, the first thing that kind
of re-caught my attention was the,
how dynamic the environment was here.
Being close to the tech space, but
the more I started to
know the community here.
What really made my decision to come
here was just being aware of how
supportive the community was.
About how people had done
really interesting things, but
also not so conventional, or
at least not in my industry.
And just how welcoming it was
to different perspectives.
>> Yeah.
>> That resonates with me, I was attracted
to Stanford primarily because of
the Center for Social Innovation.
I'm hoping to graduate with
a certificate in public management and
social innovation.
And there are so many resources and
courses here that attracted
me to this school initially.
And then similar to
what Maitane is saying,
after conversations with friends
who've gone to other business schools.
The culture of Stanford
really attracted me and
kind of reminded me of the culture
of Brown, which I enjoyed.
>> Yeah, I can second that.
As a joint degree student,
I was really looking for a community
that would be multi-disciplinary.
And I think Stanford, more than most
other business schools, is exactly that.
I also wanted to, I don't think I'm
a very entrepreneurial person or
a big risk taker.
But I definitely want to be exposed
to those types of individuals and
those types of ideas.
And I've been here for
about six months now and
I already feel as if I'm thinking
a little bit more outside the box.
I'm collaborating across
different disciplines.
And again, like Maitane said,
the community is amazing and
extremely supportive
throughout the entire journey.
>> Yeah, I think my points
have kind of been covered.
But as someone who didn't come from tech,
didn't come from the startup world.
Grew up on the East Coast, worked in
the Midwest, I was really looking for
something to push me
out of my comfort zone.
And that's something that I think has
been fulfilled here and happens over and
over again.
Depending on which class I’m in, or
which group I’m with at the moment.
I feel like I’m so
much more up to speed on tech and
entrepreneurship and
all that kind of stuff.
>> Awesome, thank you.
How certain were you on the career
you wanted to pursue prior
to starting your MBA?
>> I had no idea, [LAUGH].
Consulting kind of fell into my lap
naturally, the thing I enjoyed most
about my last job, it was similar,
it was client services.
So you're advising people on
communication strategies and
really mission-critical moments.
I realized I liked the dynamic environment
and exposure to different industries.
So consulting seemed a natural fit,
in terms of getting exposure to more
quantitative analytical problems.
While still maintaining those
client relationships and
exposure to different industries.
Though I know longer term non-profit
social sectors where I'd like to end up.
>> For me, I came in knowing I
wanted to work in sports long term.
And that was great because
ahead of time I was looking at,
which professors do I want
to make connections with?
Which alumni do I want to
potentially create connections with?
But as I've been here,
I've been tempted so
many times to change my path drastically.
Because you just get exposed to so
many different industries.
And so many different areas that Stanford
can kind of help you work towards that.
Even though I was set going in,
I've had so
many times where I've
been challenged on that.
And I've thought about so
many different industries and areas.
>> So like I said,
I'm still figuring that part out, but
what I've really enjoyed about the process
is that I think a lot of the resources and
a lot of the mindset at Stanford is to
really work with your type of time, right?
So people who know exactly
what they want to go into and
they're super focused, they'll get
the right resources to to get there,
as efficiently and as right as possible.
Whereas for other people who
are exploring different locations or
different industries,
there's also that other approach to
career management and career finding.
And so right now I'm just looking at
the different opportunities there is to
explore locations and industries, and
really making the most out of it.
because you do have a lot of exposure
to learn about different things here.
>> I definitely second
what Danny was saying.
I came in with a pretty clear
mindset of what I wanted to do.
I had done finance, I had no idea
whether I want do that again,
I drastically left and went to
the public sector, worked in nonprofit.
And I found myself wanting to
marry the two in some way, so
social impact investing
kind of just made sense.
But as I've been here and as I have
explored different paths, and what I think
Stanford does a really good job of is
showing you many different paths and
making them very tangible so
you kind of know exactly what to do if
you want to get to different directions.
And you get to talk to a lot of different
people, especially your classmate,s about
what they did before, so you see yourself
taking kind of the passions that you think
you had coming in but
finding other places to set them.
So now I'm still considering
different options.
In fact [INAUDIBLE] is something
I want to try out, but
I'm definitely now more
open than I was coming in.
>> And to that point, talking to
classmates has been probably one
of the best resources in terms
of figuring out careers and
figuring out what industries
might suit you best.
I don't know if you guys feel the same but
I feel like everyone here has been so
open and so welcoming about
sharing their experience and
grabbing coffee with you for for 30
minutes to talk about what they've done in
the past and all that kind of stuff,
which has been really helpful.
>> Yeah, totally.
>> No, I agree.
I think what's also interesting is that
you get a lot of people who are super sure
about what they wanted to do, but
just going through that process that you
talked about of being exposed to a whole
range of different things just gets
them to be super sure about it.
Or it really does spark something new.
And there's people who've made pivots and
just changed completely where they thought
they would go into coming in here.
So I think that's very cool.
>> Totally.
>> And to add to that briefly, I think the
coolest part too is that everyone's going
through the same journey here.
So maybe in your old jobs you
feel like you were an outlier,
because maybe you weren't sure if
you fit and you wanted to pivot.
Maybe you were the only one
that goes to business school.
But here,
everyone's going through the same journey.
So it's really cool to kind of go
through that journey with other people.
So even if you feel like there's never
enough time to go through everything,
you can see other journeys and
see if they actually fit with you, and
it's just a great experience.
>> Yeah.
Do you want to add something to this?
>> One quick thing, a plug for sort of
the institutional resources at Stanford.
Beyond the Career Management Center,
you also have access to the schools
across the street, which are the other
grad schools at Stanford.
So the Design School, for instance,
can really help shape your thinking around
visualizing the life that you want.
And I think that's really unique to
Stanford as a Business School student.
>> Absolutely, I can echo that I've
felt inspired here, and, yeah,
at times even a bit distracted,
like, maybe I should do that or
that sounds interesting,
because there's just so much going on.
And we know that the MBA is
a general degree, right, and
a degree where leadership skills that
we're learning here are really going to be
applicable to many different career paths.
One of our questions is,
what have you learned about leadership
that you didn't already know?
So what have you learned here at
Stanford that you didn't already know
about leadership, specifically?
>> I'll start again.
So to give a little background
on kind of a class we all take
first quarter called Leadership Labs.
So you work in a small team of five or
six students that typically come
from a wide variety of backgrounds,
and you work through different role plays,
and through different exercises.
You give each other all kinds of feedback.
You have an MBA two,
who's been trained on leadership and
these topics kind of overseeing the group.
And it's really a crash
course on leadership,
is the way I look at it throughout
the whole first quarter.
And to answer your question,
I think the one thing I learned was
how to strategically facilitate bringing
out the best of everyone on your team and
making sure that one person isn't
taking up too much space or
one person who may not be as
inclined to interrupt someone or
speak their mind extremely openly,
how to bring out and
kind of balance the conversation
to make sure you're
getting diverse perspectives and
the best out of everyone.
>> I'm going with Danny saying
in terms of Leadership Labs.
Those are really inspiring and also
transformative course for me I would say.
What I took away from it is
that anyone can be a leader.
You come in and be more introverted,
more extroverted, but
it really provides people with a platform
to experiment with the different styles,
which I thought that was
an awesome opportunity.
And one other thing is we're filmed
a few times in that class, so
it's very fun and [LAUGH] humbling to
see yourself on screen with classmates.
So, yeah.
That's probably what I've learned.
>> Not to continue the love
fest on Lead Labs, but
I completely echo everything here, so.
For some context Lead Labs, you provide
feedback with each other, and I found,
very similar to what Madison said,
that anyone could be a leader and
I found myself actually pivoting my own
leadership style based on the things that
I saw in others that I really admired.
So, for example, there was someone who
was quiet, confident, more laid back,
I'm more of a lean in, kind of louder
person, and I I found myself really want
to spend time with this other person to
learn how do they manage the stressful
environments when they're leading back,
and the cool part was he was like, hey,
I actually really wanted
to learn how you lean in.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And you know just learning how to adapt
yourself to different situations and
really start to read the rooms and
understand, okay,
leadership is all about adaptation.
So, when to be that quiet leader,
when to be that louder leader,
when to be a listener,
when to be a questioner.
So, all that kind of adaptation that
kind of comes through Lead Labs was
a great place to kind of experiment,
for a lack of a better term.
>> Yeah,
I'm not going to talk about Lead Labs.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, I think we can learn a lot here.
I mean you learn a lot about yourself.
I think that's true of a lot of programs.
But I think what's unique here is
that when we speak about the culture,
I think it has a lot of emphasis on
not only your self awareness, but
also in having other people participate
in that transformation, right?
So when we talk about
how to provide feedback,
how to help people along their journey,
and how to also bring in your own
journey to other people,
I think that's what's really important.
I think Stanford really tries to make you
kind of cross certain boundaries that you
may have set for yourself,
like fake boundaries that you're like,
I would never tell this to someone, or
I would never have this conversation
because it's very difficult.
And then all of a sudden,
you find yourself in situations
where you are going to cross that line,
but in a really positive way, right,
in a positive way that makes you grow and
really makes you work better and
just be more aware of how
you interact with others.
So I think, for me,
that's been the biggest parting
leadership development here.
>> That's awesome, thanks for sharing.
And another question we received is
about a best or most memorable course.
I know you already mentioned
Lead Labs at depths at length.
So maybe beyond Lead Labs at best or most
memorable class that you've taken so far.
>> I've really liked formation
of new ventures here.
So the objective is that you're going to
Learn about the different ways
that startups underwent this
whole journey from idea to financing,
to setting up their teams,
to everything that set them up either for
success or not success.
And so what the professors do is they
bring in the entrepreneurs, right.
So the people who actually went
through this will come to class, and
then they'll talk about how they set
up their teams, what is important?
What did they learn?
What were tough moments?
And then you get to interview, also,
an entrepreneur of your choosing.
So it's really different format of class.
And I really enjoy the fact that
the people who actually were in the case
studies would come to class and
talk to you about their experience.
>> That's awesome.
Sort of mirroring that, I took Formation
of Impact Ventures, which is the same
model, but focused on social impact
organizations, which was amazing.
So I won't repeat too much,
because it sounds like the same format,
which was incredible.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
I really enjoyed Product Launch,
which is the advanced marketing class.
It was a nice opportunity to apply what
we had learned in the fall quarter to,
in terms of strategy, financials, etc.,
to figure out how a product goes from,
again, idea to an actual company,
so I enjoyed that.
>> Yeah.
So, I would say for me,
my favorite class was,
so far, Fiscal Policy.
So as someone who's doing public policy
masters, I have no policy experience, so
that was actually my
first foray into policy.
And it's taught by Keith Hennessey,
who was, you know,
pretty high up in the Bush administration,
has tons of real-life experience, and
the way he ran the class was almost like
a mock Senate or a mock Congress, where,
you know, it was a lot of cold calling,
kind of nervous at first.
But you find yourself speaking,
you know, as if you're a congressman, or
you're pitching an idea or a policy.
And you leave class, you say,
wow, I learned a ton.
And I just think that the way that the
class was set up, and that fact that it
was not necessarily something that was
business-specific, but kind of out of
the realm, just made me appreciate
the classmates that I had even more.
All of the experience we brought in
that had nothing to do with the kind of
traditional business,
like finance or something like that.
>> Awesome.
Yeah, I've heard great things all of those
classes, but haven't taken any of them,
so I've got to get them on my list for
next year.
So my favorite class so
far, without a doubt,
has been the sports management class.
So it's taught by George Foster,
as well as two practitioners.
So the way that works is,
we have a regular Stanford professor,
accompanied with one or
two industry leaders.
So that will happen in a bunch of classes,
especially in electives,
and our two practitioners were Dave Kaval,
who is the president of the Oakland As,
and Sam Hinkie, who's former general
manager for the Philadelphia 76ers.
And what I liked so
much about the class was,
aside from having these people who
have done so much in the industry, and
are such big names, was,
it was really guest speaker led.
So we'd have a different guest speaker or
two every week.
We had people including the president
of the San Francisco Giants.
We had leaders from the WNBA,
leaders from, really,
all the major sports in the US,
and some internationally.
And the class was almost just
a conversation between the students,
the professor, the practitioners,
and our guests.
And it really gave us an inside look
into all these different industries.
And if you're interested in the sports
industry, it's such a no-brainer class,
and if you're just interested in sports in
general, it's just a fascinating view into
the world that you just
typically just don't get.
>> That's great, yeah, and I'll add that
I think it's funny that all our favorite
classes are so
tied into things that we're interested in.
One of my favorite classes that I've
taken so far is called Family Business.
And it's taught by a GSB grad,
Leo Linbeck,
who flew out from Texas every
week to teach this to us.
And what was really interesting for
me was that his perspectives were so
different, and it's like a different
vantage point from tech.
And so it was really fun to hear his take
on how you run and grow family businesses.
So, pivoting a little bit away
from the classroom setting.
Another question has come in about, beyond
the HBSA, what types of organizations
and/or resources are available at
Stanford for Hispanic students?
Let's speak a little of that.
>> Yeah, so I mean, for me,
there's a center on campus,
El Centro Chicano y Latino.
So it's it's for
the general community at large.
So they have tons of events,
cultural events.
It's a space that you kind of just use,
go and hang out.
You'll meet a ton of folks
from other programs.
So, I mean I think maybe
I met two other MBAs, and
everyone else was from other programs.
So it's just another space, and
another avenue to explore, to get to know
the broader community at Stanford,
the Latino community at Stanford.
So that that's one thing I would
definitely say was a was a good find, and
a really cool place to be.
>> Let's say for my experience,
being from Mexico City,
is the joint collaborations
that there are between HBSA and
LASA, which is the Latin American Student
Association, are just a great way of kind
of understanding those two
different perspectives, and
they're two communities that
are really supportive with each other.
So those things, I think, are also great
resources to, you know, make advantage.
>> Yeah, and then I know HBSA last week
had a mixer bringing together different
Latino groups from
different grad programs.
So that was a fun way to meet people, and
I think we're planning to do
more of those events this year.
>> Yeah, and I couldn't make it, but
I know that students from the law
school were there, the medical school.
And Jerry, you saw something?
>> Yeah.
>> That's awesome.
I love that.
Okay.
Next question is about Stanford, and
how Stanford helps foster diversity and
inclusion.
Can you guys speak to that?
>> Sure.
I mean, so starting, I believe,
in week zero, there there's a kickoff
event called Engage, which brings
together practitioners who do diversity
equity and inclusion work outside.
Outside in the Bay Area, they're
consultants for different companies.
So that's a day-long presentation,
where you're with your section, and
you go through different exercises, just
to establish a culture of inclusivity in
your section, and
then hopefully that extends to your class.
I'm a member of the Diversity Committee
as part of the Student Association, so
I have a vantage point on planning for
next year.
So we're planning to
continue that program, and
build upon it in some exciting ways.
Beyond that, there are a number of student
identity groups like HBSA, like LASA,
like BBSA, which is
the Black Business Student Association.
So I think that those groups all run
fantastic events that recur throughout
the year.
So you get a consistent
feeling of inclusivity and
belonging throughout your class, but
also between classes and BA1s and BA2s.
We're also working with the administration
to push different initiatives forward,
to recruit even more diverse viewpoints
and students to come into future classes.
>> Yeah, and I would give other push
towards kind of the admissions process.
I've been blown away by the diversity
of our class, both physical diversity,
ethnic diversity, diversity of thought,
diversity of background,
really anything you're interested in,
on the background,
everything you're interested in,
there's magically someone who has deep
knowledge in that specific area,
which always blows my mind.
But I really think that the admissions
team does a fantastic job of bringing
in people from all over the world,
with all different kinds of experiences.
All different kinds of strengths,
weaknesses, and
career plans and aspirations.
And I thinks that makes for
really strong group dynamics and
kind of a safe space to
kind of be different and
have different ideas, different thoughts.
>> Just to add on that.
I also think that if you find that
the group an identity group or
something doesn't exist on campus,
you can create it, and
you'll find the people
that fit that group.
So I'm working with some students here
to start the first generation and
low income group.
We haven't had one before.
We weren't sure exactly
what the interest would be.
We send out a email,
we got about 50 responses back.
And-
>> Over 100.
>> Over 100 now.
Yeah, there it is.
So over 100 now, of people who
were either identify as such or
want to be advocates of such a program.
So just the fact that we were able
to do that, just put it in place,
it was a fairly smooth transition
between us and the administration.
And just as again,
diversity continues to change and evolve,
I think you'll be able to find a place
on campus to create what you want.
>> I see.
I think what I would add is, just outside
the formal structures of just like
clubs and societies and associations,
I think there's a real interest
from people who just to understand
other perspectives, right?
So, for example, I think I see
here more than in other schools or
perhaps just in other
experiences I've had.
Like the people will really go above and
beyond to understand
a different perspective.
So they'll be like, okay,
let's organize small group dinners to
talk about this particular topic that
perhaps we're not really digging
deep enough to understand it.
Or let's organize ask me anythings,
or let's do x type of event.
Or can you share with us what it's
like to work in this country or
this other country?
And I think that interest and
how curious and how open the community is,
and how much it translates that curiosity
into something tangible that people
can take away with them really helps
with diversity and inclusion and
just bringing all these things
together into your MBA experience.
>> Absolutely.
And can you just expand on what ask me
anythings are for our audience,
that may not know?
>> Sure.
>> So it is like it's an informal session
where somebody will volunteer and you can
ask them anything for about nine minutes.
And so it's just an opportunity
to get to know people better.
Like I think I've been asked really
interesting questions from my background,
from places I've lived in.
And I've also unexpectedly found out
something really random about a classmate.
For example, one of my classmates,
it turns out he used to play
classic music professionally.
And we had no clue he was a musician.
So you will always find out
something really interesting and
really fun about someone.
But also you can really understand
a perspective when it come to
diversity a lot better.
>> Absolutely.
And one of the favorite questions for
AMAs is always,
what matters most to you and why, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE] unfamiliar.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, another question that's
come in, and kind of going off of what
you were saying, David, was about any of
us being first time MBAs in our family.
And if so, how did you navigate some of
the challenges of the application and
internship process?
So, maybe by a show of hands,
who's a first time MBA in your family?
Okay, great, so can you speak to
little bit of the challenges and
how we overcame them?
>> Yeah, so I can start, so I think for
me, navigating these waters for
the first time,
you deal with a lot of different things.
One, you may not understand
how the process works.
Another part is self-doubt,
and really not sure where you're going to
fit into the pile of amazing applicants.
>> And what I did is, first thing I
think is important is to understand
that being vulnerable throughout
the entire process is power.
So whether it be reaching out to alumni
and asking questions or putting yourself
out there at an admissions event to
talk to the admissions officer and
ask the questions that you really,
really need to understand and know.
Going in and breaking down your own
narrative and owning that narrative.
I think are all part of the application
process that truly allowed me to grow
into not just being
comfortable applying or
going through the challenge, but also
just kind of saying, owning myself and
my story, regardless of whether I was
going to get into Stanford or not.
So I think that was really big for me.
I also had a little bit of fun with it,
right?
So my family didn't know what an MBA was.
So I had fun educating them and
kind of like walking them the process and
I brought them into kind of
the application process and
having that support even if it's not,
when I applied to an MBA I did this.
But just saying hey,
what do you think about this story?
You remember when this happened?
And we would kind of reminisce, and
really help me think through
my narrative and story.
So I think even if your family or the
people around you are not quite familiar
with it, bring them into the process.
Because in the end of the day, it's about
owning your narrative and your story.
>> That was really well put,
hard to follow.
I think I would echo what David just said,
but I really emphasize,
don't be shy about turning to mentors and
seeking those people out,
whether or not they have an MBA.
I had to explain the decision to my family
and they didn't understand like but
you went to a good undergrad program,
why do you need this degree?
And I realized I wasn't happy
in the career I had chosen and
that I needed an MBA to pivot to things
that I cared or rather I wanted an MBA in
order to effect change at a greater scale
and towards something that I cared about.
So I really relied on my mentors
that I had cultivated in both
the office setting but
also from years before in undergrad.
And they were really helpful in
terms of navigating the process, and
again helping me flesh out my story,
like David said.
And not being shy about being vulnerable
and honest about the experiences that
had shaped me and why I thought I
would be a good candidate here.
>> I think another thing to look into is
that there are programs out there that
help, specifically, Black and
Hispanic potential MBA applicants.
Like MLT, Management Leaders for Tomorrow.
So to David's point and
to Madison's point,
seek out informal mentors,
put yourself out there.
And really look for
ways that you can become more informed
on the MBA application process
to give yourself kind of the opportunity
to put your best foot forward.
>> Yeah, and I don't want to speak for
the group but folks who are watching,
I'd be happy to talk to anyone
who's watching who has questions.
>> Definitely.
>> Same.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You can always get in touch with us.
And we'll have more information about how
to get in touch with us towards the end.
Okay, so
first in our families to get MBAs,
navigating which programs to choose,
we're now at Stanford.
What's been most surprising
about this experience?
Was there anything unexpected?
>> I think the degree of personal
change that the program ignites.
[LAUGH] We all go in here wanting to
refine and improve our soft skills,
leadership skills, and
you expect all that.
But I don't think that you really
understand how much you're
putting yourself up to expose
yourself to really question
perhaps fundamental things about
yourself or about your career.
So it may be like what we spoke about,
that you may just have a complete,
180 change of what you want to do in life.
But it may also be things like
you may understand something
about yourself through this whole like
leadership development or through other
Interactions that you didn't know or
you hadn't thought about it before, or
you hadn't recognized what
impact it has on others.
And so that really feels like this
motivation and this passion to grow and
to challenge yourself.
But sometimes it's tough because you're
going to have to make difficult decisions
about your career and
your personal life and yourself.
But I think that's what's great.
It was a surprise that it would be
such a big scale like change perhaps,
but it's something really satisfying.
>> So
I would echo a lot of what she just said.
Like I said,
I believe that vunerability is power,
that's why I was attracted to Stanford.
I was not prepared for
how much that was the case.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we discuss AMAs, there's also
a talk series where one of our classmates
will go up and share their narrative.
Even in Lee Labs, I think all of
us cried in Lee Labs at one point.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's touchy feely,
which is a class I haven't taken yet.
Apparently, everyone cries so
here we go again.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I just think that's really unique
to Stanford.
I don't know many other, I have a lot of
friends that are in other MBA programs,
I don't think that's always the case.
And one thing I would also add, too,
is how much resources are available here.
I think you also have an idea that an MBA
program's going to have a lot of great
resources.
But if I think of something it exists,
and it's something that's valuable, and
I can take advantage of.
So I think allowing yourself to be open
to everything and to really look for
the resources that are out there already.
I mean, there's just so
much to take advantage of that that was
one of the biggest surprises for me.
>> Yeah.
I've been surprised by how much learning
takes place outside of the classroom.
I think we said that a lot in the
beginning, but our classmates have really
been such a source of insight, different
perspective, out of our comfort zones.
Oftentimes I've found myself
at a small group dinner and
am like, I'm the only American here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And just the learning and
the openness that people bring
to the table has shocked me.
>> I've also been really
surprised at how busy we've been.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
just how much we're constantly
forced to make trade offs.
We talked about the mixer that
HPSA hosted the other night, and
they couldn't make it because there were
literally three other things happening.
And there was this wonderful screening
taking place, a film, a documentary
called, Groomed, that a GSB alumni put
together, and I just couldn't miss it.
But I think I've been really surprised
that the amount, the optionality, I guess.
And all the things happening, and really
the reality that we can't take it all in.
And I'm reminded of how Disneyland
wasn't designed to allow you to go
on every ride in one day or
even a week, and the GSB is that way.
We have two short years here,
and it's really not designed for
you to take every class and
do everything, but
to make your own, pick what you
want from the buffet kind of thing.
>> You guys completely covered
everything [LAUGH] I had thought of.
>> Yeah, cool, so
we have a career question.
How does the campus recruiting
process work at the GSB, and
what types of resources
does Stanford offer?
I can give you this one off.
So there's a few different
types of processes.
So one, there are a set of companies and
a set of industries that will
do formal on campus recruiting.
They'll have info sessions
around November or December.
They have formal application processes and
interview processes that they've been
doing, and coordinating with Stanford
career team for years and years and years.
That's kind of the stuff like
consulting and investment banking.
Some of the tech companies,
and then aside from that,
we have one of the best resources is just
the alumni, so I've been blown away.
I guess one of the things that surprised
me most is how helpful the alumni been,
and how responsive they've been when I
just cold reach out via email to an alum
that's in an industry that's relevant for
me.
So that's been a great source.
There's also a never-ending list
of internships, and so we're all
first year so we're more experienced
with the internship recruiting process.
But a never-ending list of internships
posted that scroll through, and
have alerts set up to forward
me stuff that's in a location or
industry I'm interested in.
And then lastly, sorry to take so
many of these, but
we have a pretty large career team.
And no matter the industry you're in,
how large or how small,
there is a career advisor
dedicated to your industry.
So for sports for example, there's maybe
only a couple people each year that
are interested in that,
there's actually a career advisor,
one I met with yesterday,
who specializes in sports.
So that's been a great resource for
me as well.
And then on the flip side,
there's also the Stanford career
team that works on reaching out
to different companies, and
establishing formal connections
between them and Stanford.
And again, there's someone dedicated to
sports, despite how niche it might seem.
>> Yeah, I think that was a very
thorough explanation of the resources.
>> Sorry.
>> No, it's great.
One thing I'd add, we have blast email,
which is sort of a list that
connects all the MBA ones, MBA twos.
And people will just throw different
opportunities out from their old
companies, etc., and even networking
with students in our class are MBA twos.
They'll know someone who knows someone
who's looking for an intern, so
that's a good resource,
as well as student clubs, I would say, but
beyond that I think Danny covered it.
The only thing I would add which is
something that I'm doing this summer,
is taking advantage of
the global experiences.
So there's GMIX, which is the opportunity
for you to go and work for a company for
a minimum of four weeks in a different
country that you never lived or worked in.
And so, it just gives you the chance
to explore a new location,
perhaps a new industry,
it's a really easy way to do that.
And so, there's GMIX,
which is through the GSP.
There's also kind of broader
Stanford opportunities,
like through Seed, which is a program
that we have to help entrepreneurs
in the developing world build
up their management skill set.
And then towards the end of the program,
they get access to offer internships
as well, to the Standford community.
So then that's something that business
students can also tap into if they're
interested in working in emerging markets.
>> Yeah, I guess one thing to add, it's
not necessaritly a formal resource, but
I would say there's a lot of things
that happen here that are informal.
So the cool thing about going to
Stanford and having a Stanford MBA is
that the majority of people you reach out
to, whether it's a call or the email, or
something of that nature,
they'll reach back out to you.
So I'm going into an industry that there's
not a lot of recruiting that goes on, so
a lot of it had to be
me hitting the ground.
And I know it sounds kind if intimidating
at first, but you realize that's kind
of part of being at Stanford, at being
in the entrepreneurial environment.
There's also a lot of other classmates
who I think, for a lot of folks coming to
an MBA, they feel like okay,
an MBA is kind of the means to the end.
And you realize the NBA is a means and
of itself, and
folks will come in thinking that they're
ready to hit this recruiting cycle.
And then, you talk to them now,
they're kind of like, yeah, you know,
I'm just going to start my own thing or
I'm going to create my own project for
the summer or I'm going to join
a start-up to try something new.
So I think that's another
thing that is unspoken,
but I think a lot of things
happen in that avenue.
>> Yeah, and to that point,
on the entrepreneurship part, something we
didn't touch on was, there is a wealth of
resources for people who want to start
their own companies, or work for small
start ups over the summer or full time.
So there is certainly no lack of
resources for entrepreneurs as well.
>> Great, and we're coming towards
the end of our time together today.
One question that I think would be
great to kind of round this out.
Knowing what you know now, about Stanford
and the GSB and this experience,
if you could start all over again,
rewind back to September,
is there anything you
would do differently?
Or even maybe rewind back through
the application process, before?
Yeah, what would you do differently?
>> I think going back to your
point about the resources and
an optionality I wish I would have spent
a little bit more time thinking about
the path that I at least wanted
to start on when I got here.
I think for the first like month or
two, I came kind of thinking,
let's be completely open-minded.
There's too much.
It's so hard to be completely open-minded,
and you start to get FOMO because
you're making too many trade offs.
I think, had I spent maybe a little
bit more time in the front end,
just exploring what actually existed,
coming in with some type of plan to then
pivot from would have been really helpful.
>> I'd second that, but I think I had
a slightly different take, which was,
I think a lot of people, or the majority
of people here, are used to being able
to do everything in a very short amount
of time and being very efficient.
And so, sometimes you're under
the illusion that you will be able to do
everything once you're here,
and you're not.
And so I think just taking the time,
I think taking some time, a,
just to like, shift gears before
coming to business school,
really getting your priorities set.
Then you are able to articulate
just what you're working towards or
what you don't know that
you want to explore.
It's really important because, yeah,
you won't be able to do everything, and
just being able to prioritize
makes a huge difference.
>> Yeah, those are certainly, well, that's
definitely what I would do differently,
starting at the GSP.
But looking back to the application
process, I think it would have been more
useful for me to start the essay
drafting process sooner.
And really key into what
story I wanted to tell.
Because I think it's important to
tell a story in your essay and
that occurred to me a little
later in the process.
I wish I had brainstormed that
a bit more strategically.
>> Taking it back to the GSB, one thing
I wished I'd have done differently.
I think I realized later than I would
have wanted to how open alums and
professors are to get coffee with you,
to meet up with you, etc.
And I still have another
year to go to do this, but
I'm just now starting to have
informal conversations with alums,
have breakfast and
coffee with professors in my industry.
And I wish I would have taken
advantage of that from day one,
as opposed to in quarter three.
>> That's awesome.
I think I would echo all of that,
and I'm so grateful for
the time we got to spend together today,
so thank you for joining.
And thank you to our audience for
participating in this event and for
your great questions.
Thank you for joining us today.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC]